the presidential campaign trail and a
rare apology senator Bernie Sanders
apologized to former Vice President Joe
Biden in an exclusive interview with CBS
News this followed a newspaper op-ed
from a Sanders surrogate accusing Biden
of having a quote corruption problem ed
O'Keefe is in Des Moines ed with the
Iowa caucuses less than two weeks away
why this apology
well good morning aunt remember the race
for president remains a toss-up so all
the candidates are looking for some way
to break through in this op-ed Zephyr
Teachout a New York liberal and
prominent Sanders surrogate argues that
Joe Biden has a corruption problem for
taking contributions from wealthy donors
she writes middle-class Joe has
perfected the art of taking big
contributions than representing his
corporate donors at the cost of middle
and working-class americans the op-ed
was later circulated by the Sanders
campaign the Biden campaign quickly
swung back and other observers suggest
that the attacks are part of a pattern
for Sanders dating back to his 2016
campaign when he faced criticism for not
stopping supporters from aggressively
attacking opponents like Hillary Clinton
or more recently Elizabeth Warren in
Biden when we caught up with senator
Sanders last night in that exclusive
interview he called on his supporters to
play nice Joe and I have strong
disagreements on a number of issues and
will argue those disagreements out but
it is absolutely not my view that Joe is
is corrupt in any way and I'm sorry that
that op-ed appeared to me I appeal to my
supporters please engaged in civil
discourse and by the way we're not the
only campaign that does it other people
do you know act that way as well
but I would appeal to everybody have a
debate on the issues we can disagree
with each other without being
disagreeable disagreeable without being
people in response last night but Biden
tweeted his thanks to Sanders and said
these kinds of attacks have no place in
this primary Biden is out on the trail
here in Iowa today holding two events
while the senator is running for
president of course are back in
Washington for that impeachment trial
but Sanders is deploying a big
supporter here to Iowa in the coming
days congresswoman alexandria Ocasio
cortez of new york will hold events for
him
Friday and Saturday Gale I think it was
Elton John who once said sorry seems to
be the hardest word for whatever reason
last night Bernie Sanders could say it
and it sounded good to a lot of people
still discourse it's a good thing seems
really stays thank you very much
at O'Keefe reporting
you